ROB PASKOWSKI: Well, thanks
everyone for coming today.
Good afternoon.
My name is Rob Paskowski, and
I'm on the Google benefits team
here in Sunnyvale, California.
And I focus on managing our
Google US health care strategy.
The team sponsoring
this event asked
me to speak because of my
experience as a benefits
professional, as a leader in
the Google People Operations,
but also, being a dad
and being an autism dad.
So a father to nine-year-old
son with autism.
So you see, my journey
as a People Operations
guy, a benefits
professional, really
did change in 2009 when my
son was diagnosed with autism.
And quickly after the shock
and everything that goes,
the emotions that go into
that, after helping my son get
the services he needed
and everything like that,
I quickly realised that there
was a gap in the services
provided to parents who
have special needs children,
both in therapy and benefits,
but also in leave programs.
So I had set out on
a journey, and this
parallels some of
the work that Josh is
doing around parental benefits.
But I set out on my own
journey at that point
to see how can we help other
special needs families deal
with this dilemma, whether
it's coverage for therapy,
or leave benefits,
and things like that.
So I set out on a mission
to develop an autism support
program and benefits program for
the company I was working out
at the time.
And it worked, out worked
with consultants, worked
with the autism advocacy
groups, and with the insurance
carriers, as well to
put something together
that could really
work for families.
So we put in something
I was really, really
proud of, but then
realized that hey,
this was just one organization.
How can we really
change the culture
around how we support
parents in this little niche
around special needs?
And then I started working
with the advocacy groups
to do with more employers;
so get more employers
to understand,
hearing it from a dad,
but also from a
benefits professional
that I could speak the
same language to them
and help them set up
their own program.
So I was able to scale that
and help over a dozen companies
implement comprehensive
autism support
programs that leave benefits
to support their employees.
And I have spoken at a
number of conferences
to help others just
dispel the myths
and really get the
true information out
there about how they can
really help their families.
And the results have been
amazing that you just
have more loyal employees.
There's a business
value to all the things
Josh is going to talk about.
There's a business
value to the things
that we've done in
the autism community
really to help those families.
People will be loyal.
They will bend over
backwards when you really
support them and support them in
taking care of their families.
I'm also proud of the
work we do at Google.
So the work we do at
Google, we've been,
I think, one of the pioneers
on paternity and maternity
benefits.
We continue to try to set the
standard not just for Googlers.
But how we can set the
standard, and then others
will follow our lead to
offer similar programs
to their employees to
support their families.
So it's not just about Google.
It's how can we do something
really innovative and creative
here for our people that then
we can transport that out
to the world?
So today, it's an honor to
introduce you to Josh Levs.
And he's going to inspire
you about his story
and his amazing journey to
dispel some of those myths
about traditional
roles of moms and dads
and advocate for
what I was talking
about earlier, the
business value of offering
these types of paid maternity
benefits to employees.
So without further delay,
I'd like to welcome Josh up
to the podium.
JOSH LEVS: So I've prepared
all this on Google Slides,
but I want to show
you guys something.
So I started off with
this YouTube video.
But I'm going to show it to
you directly from the computer,
because one thing I need you
guys to fix about Google Slides
is that you can't avoid the ads.
So I was giving this
speech in Tennessee.
And I went to show
this video, and it
was a relatively
conservative crowd.
And right before this video, all
of a sudden, an ad for Viagra
popped up.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Being a dad, I just
loved this story.
And thankfully, some
dads took action.
Basically, what do they
want for Father's Day?
For the media to stop
portraying dads as buffoons,
doofus dads, right?
That's all we ever see.
It's not just one or two shows.
It's frankly, every show.
And Josh Levs joins us now.
And Josh, you and
I are both dads.
You've got little ones.
I've got teenagers.
And enough's enough, and I love
it that some dads stood up.
-It's so true,
isn't It you can't
avoid the caricature of us, as
dads, as being just complete
idiots who can't understand
how to do anything.
-Nothing.
-Often who don't know how to
take care of our children.
-We're practically another kid
in the home in most TV shows.
-But just so everyone knows,
this isn't a whine session.
Now, what's so
interesting to me is
that dads are doing
something about this now.
They're standing
up and fighting,
and I have some proof that
they're making a difference.
So here's what
we're going to do.
We're going to start
off with an ad that
aired earlier this year that
was just obviously offensive.
Take a look here.
-To prove Huggies diapers and
wipes can handle anything,
we put them to the toughest
test imaginable-- dads alone
with their babies in
one house for five days.
-So in that ad, Huggies
said the biggest
test imaginable for diapers is
to leave kids alone with dad.
-We can't handle
the diaper, right?
-Oh, of not.
Ew, gross.
They had another one
where the dads didn't
change the diapers throughout an
entire game on double overtime.
-So what happened here is a
bunch of dads got together.
They started petitioning online.
One guys started a petition.
A lot of people
complained online.
Huggies took it
really seriously.
They jumped on it.
They said whoa, this
was not what we meant.
They called one of the dads.
They pulled two ads.
They replaced them
with brand new ads,
and here's one of the new ones.
Take a look.
-Awesome.
-To prove Huggies wipes
can handle anything,
we asked real dads to
put them to the test
with their own babies
on spaghetti night.
-Totally different
message there.
We asked dads to put
them to the test,
and you see this
happening elsewhere.
-Dad's cooking, as well.
He's cooking a meal.
-Dad's feeding.
And so I started to
talk to some pop culture
analysts and some dads.
And they're saying,
you know what?
Little by little, we're
making a difference.
We're combating this area.
-And I agree with
you, and I don't
want to sound like the
whining dad either.
And I'm OK with
poking fun at dad.
-Yeah.
-But it's every show.
And you and I talked about
it from Homer Simpson,
Peter Griffin.
And those are funny,
but it's every show.
And I want to get
your take on this.
What concerns me
is my sons, what
do they watch on television?
-Right.
-Whether it's the Disney
Channel, Nickelodeon,
or all shows, what
they're seeing--
and media's powerful--
that dad's an idiot.
Dad's a doofus.
I hope I'm giving
another example at home.
Maybe not all the
time, but I'm trying.
-And look, the best example
they're ever going to get
is from you, because they're
going to learn from you.
But a lot of the dads I
talked to said the same thing.
They said pop culture
does give kids messages.
Some boys out there
are going to think
that that's the low bar
he's expected to rise to.
Some girls out
there will grow up
to become women who have
very low expectations for how
good fathers their
husbands will be,
because we keep feeding
them all these portrayals
of these really lame,
really bad dads.
And in fact, you used
a couple examples.
There's a guy I talked to, runs
a blog called, "The Dadvocate"
where he said, take a
look at Homer Simpson.
He said the same thing
about Peter Griffin,
some of these cartoons.
Now, there are also
good dads on TV now.
You've got different
portrayals on Modern Family.
You have a stay-at-home
dad in "Up All Night."
So you can look at TV in
general and see more diversity.
And some of the people I
talked to said actually,
you're seeing a little bit
more change one step at a time.
But what needs to happen is
more conversations like this.
And there were dads out
there talking about it saying
we are not this stereotype.
Stop doing that to us.
-Is Ward Cleaver coming back?
-You know what's interesting?
Back in the day, we're good.
Weren't dads great
back in the day?
And then it was
just decades later
that they decided to
start skewering dads,
and everybody decided to
do the exact same joke
of the doofus dad.
It caught on just a little
too much to the point
that it's getting too hard
to find the good dads.
-That's the complaint, yeah.
Good stuff.
-Listen, everyone can
check it out, cnn.com.
We will hold story about this.
This is up on Facebook
and Twitter too.
I hope everyone weighs in,
dads and moms across America.
-Because not everybody
agrees with us.
Hey, open conversation.
Not everybody agrees with us.
-That's right.
-Some will say we're whiners.
We're not.
Just want equal representation.
-But we will listen to you.
-Good stuff, Josh.
Thanks so much.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JOSH LEVS: So here's
what happened.
So I used to report on these.
I was reporting on this
kind of thing at CNN.
I was doing all these
stories about fathers
and representations of fathers.
And any time I would do a story
like that some people would
say to me, relax.
TV makes fun of everybody.
It's about caricature.
This is what everyone does.
But what people don't
understand or didn't understand
is that these negative
portrayals of dads
are a symptom of a
larger problem that
has very serious
consequences for us,
and I'm going to tell you
about those consequences.
One of them is this.
This was my 4-pound
preemie baby.
I was torn away from her.
I couldn't care for
her, and I couldn't
be home with my very sick wife.
I'm going to tell
you that story.
This is another symptom
of the same problem.
There's this.
This is what's
happening with women
in the workforce
in this country.
So what you have is the
more red, the more women.
So at the beginning
of the board, what's
the lowest one for
the work force,
upon entering the work
force, women are almost 50%--
assuming they're going to be
a little bit more than 50%.
As you go off the higher ranks,
women start to disappear.
This is the S&P 500.
Less than 5% of
the CEOs are women.
This is another symptom
of that same problem.
But the worst symptom that
we have of all is this.
We are the only developed
country that pulls babies away
from parents right away,
that doesn't make sure
that there's some kind of
net so that after a birth,
a parent can be
home with the baby
and put food on the table for
at least a block of weeks.
We're the only nation
that does this.
Now, I have had reason
to learn about this.
And I learned some
of it the hard way.
But take a look at this map.
So the map here, the
countries in red-- I
say countries, even
though it's really
just us and two tiny little
ones, Suriname and Papua New
Guinea, tiny islands.
The countries in
red are the ones
that don't have paid
maternity leave programmed.
We hear a lot of
complaints about this,
but no one ever talks about why.
No one ever explains
where it comes from.
Well, it all comes from the
exact same place as those ads.
It comes from the "Mad Men" era.
This is when our new
work culture was created.
We were coming out of the war.
We were creating
this new economy,
and this new economy was
built on work life balance.
And the balance was that men
stay at work all the time,
and women stay
home all the time.
It was this very
strict, genuine way
for making a new work culture.
And a lot of us think that the
country has come a long way,
but it actually hasn't.
Our work structures were
built entirely in that era.
So what you have
all over the nation
are people who are still
running companies, who still
believe that that's what it is.
It's ingrained in us,
because it's been there now
for a few generations.
And we don't think
twice about it.
I have learned about this.
I've been covering this
throughout my career.
I started at NPR.
This is major little
background on me.
I've covered big businesses.
I've covered around the world.
So this was me doing
fact checking on CNN.
And so what happened was when
I started wearing my glasses,
more and more people
started taking me seriously.
So I got more and more
chance-- it's so ridiculous.
I started doing more chances
to do fact checking on CNN.
This is TV news for you.
So all these politicians
from all sides.
And the pundits would literally
say whatever they want,
anything; whatever they want.
And they would get away with it,
and no one would correct them.
And that was a huge problem.
So I was like, wait a second.
Can we just start fact
checking these things?
So I started fact
checking these things.
And then I ended
up applying that
to the other, more
important part of my life.
This is my career.
But who I really am, in
a bigger way, is a dad.
That's number one to me.
And becoming a father,
becoming a parent,
it's always usually dramatic.
But in my case, it was
exceptionally dramatic,
in our case, because in
every one of our births,
we've had a wild story.
This is my son; my first son.
When he was two days
old, we found out
that he had a heart defect,
but a very serious heart defect
at that.
And so at seven days, this
is what he looked like.
And I share this picture
because yes, it's horrifying,
and it was a nightmare.
But this is also
beautiful, because this
is a story of humanity.
We adapt to survive.
This is what we do.
This is why I care so much
about coming to businesses
like Google, because
this spirit of innovation
is how we come up
with stuff like this.
It's how we fix things.
It's also why I never listen
to cynics, because cynics
are the ones who
would say oh, we'll
never find a way to fix a tiny
little valve in a baby's heart.
Innovation, to
me, is everything.
And here is my kid a year later.
They fixed it.
So I'm constantly
reminded of how important
it is to innovate, because
that's that human spark that
makes us who we are.
So that was baby number one.
Then with baby number
two we thought OK.
This time, we'll have
relatively drama free birth.
But that didn't happen.
So this time, my
wife and the baby
conspired to skip
labor altogether.
She was three weeks
before her due date.
She fell to the floor and
couldn't say anything.
And suddenly, stuff started
coming out into my hands.
And then I saw his head,
but his eyes were closed,
and he wasn't moving.
And then I saw his neck
and the umbilical cord
was wrapped around
his neck five times.
And then he entirely
came out into my hand.
Now, he turned out
perfectly, too.
Everything worked great.
I'm going to share with
you all a little clip
from my 9-1-1 call that day.
I did this story more
than a year later,
when I felt ready that
I could handle it.
Here goes.
This is where I had a segment
with my colleague, Sanjay
Gupta.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --four hours of labor,
which are standard.
With this one, all
of a sudden, she
felt something, bent
over by the bed,
was feeling something
even more powerful,
got down on the floor.
Boom.
Within a couple of minutes.
-So no contractions beforehand?
Because she knows
what it feels like.
-She knows all the
steps very well,
and she knows what
the feelings would be.
This is incredibly unusual,
but it happened to her.
So she's down on the floor
and says, call an ambulance.
I get on the phone with 9/11.
Here's a little clip
at what happened.
-What do I do?
I'm holding my baby's head.
-OK, listen.
I want you to support
the shoulders.
-OK.
-And hold the hips
and legs firmly.
-OK.
-And remember, the baby will be
slippery, so don't drop it, OK?
-OK.
-So is the baby completely
out, or just the head?
-No, just the head.
I'm seeing the head.
It's all scrunched up.
But it's not crying.
It's not making noise.
Its eyes are shut.
-OK.
Have her to push hard
and get the baby out, OK?
-Got to push hard,
get the baby out.
Push hard, push hard.
Oh my god, I'm holding my baby!
It's an umbilical cord,
and there's something
wrapped around its neck.
I'm taking it off.
-OK, listen.
Gently wipe the baby's
mouth and nose--
-It's choking.
It's choking on the chord.
Breathe baby, breathe.
I'm taking the chord off.
-Let me give you a CPR
specialist for the baby, OK?
-OK.
The baby's breathing.
-Is the baby breathing?
-Yeah, it's breathing.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JOSH LEVS: So it worked out.
And you can see in there
that there were 84 seconds
that we skipped.
So there was a while
before we could
see that he was breathing.
This also gave me
a new commitment
to and appreciation
for being a journalist,
because it was just so
random that I knew something.
What I didn't plan there
was that the 9-1-1 operator
was telling me to tie off his
umbilical cord with a shoe
lace.
And I just happened to
know that you're not
supposed to do that until you
can see the baby's breathing.
So I always keep
in mind, you never
know what random fact
might actually help you.
And that was because my
nephew had a traumatic birth.
And they thought he
wasn't going to make it.
But he did, because he
was still getting oxygen
from the umbilical cord.
So anyway, all of this,
what it did was it
helped drill into
me my real values
in this life, that family
is number one; that this
is everything to me, that this
is always going to be the most
important part of who I am.
And especially after
my second son's birth
I stopped overworking,
and I started
really looking for a work-life
balance, and work life
integration, and the
right way to live,
and the right way to make
sure that I was there
for all the moments.
Because in that moment
when he was being born,
it was so obvious to
me that nothing else
matters except family, when
that's how you live your life.
So after this, I started
talking to other dads
about what they
were going through
and what their experiences were.
And this was also
around the time
after the financial crisis,
when the economy fell apart.
I like to call it a
financial fiasco, actually.
So I was interviewing
groups of dads.
And when Father's Day
came around in 2009
it seemed like the
most obvious thing
to me, to do a bunch of
segment talking to dads.
And we talked about everything.
We talked about our
financial stresses,
what we want for our kids, our
positions on gender equality,
what we want in our careers.
And the responses that
we got to these segments
were out of proportion.
They were huge.
People were calling us, and
writing us, and e-mailing.
And I started getting calls
from other media wanting
to interview me about being a
dad in the media who interviews
dads, because no one had
seen anything like this.
And this forced me to
realize that no one had ever
seen real dads, that
stereotypes still ruled the day.
So seeing dads talk about actual
issues that we care about.
It was just a new
idea to most people.
All these parenting
segments on air
had been about women;
maybe one token dad,
maybe one token
stay-at-home dad.
But having a group of dads
really open up was a new idea.
So I made that a part of what
I did, and I started covering
fatherhood a lot more.
And then we thought, OK.
When my wife was pregnant
with baby number we were like,
this is going to be it.
Third time's a
charm, drama free.
And instead, she and I ended up
on the front page of "The New
York Times" business section.
So here's what happened there.
My wife was pregnant,
and we looked
at things that were
going on in our family.
And we knew that because of her
health and a business, a work
opportunity she
had, that I would
be needed at home to
do some care giving
after the baby's birth.
Now, to all modern couples,
that is a completely
normal and legitimate concept.
There's nothing strange about
it and nothing unusual about it.
More and more men are taking
time to care for our kids.
Unfortunately, corporate America
has not kept up with this idea.
So I was under this
incredibly weird policy
at CNN under which
anyone can get 10 paid
weeks to care for their
new baby except a man
who impregnated his own wife.
So it's as weird as it sounds.
So I give up my
daughter for adoption,
and another guy at the
company adopted her,
he would get 10 paid weeks.
If we used a surrogate, I
could get 10 paid weeks.
If I had a same sex
domestic partner
and he adopted a baby but
I did not adopt his baby,
so I'm not a
co-adoptive parent, I
could still get 10 paid
weeks to care for his baby.
But I, the real me-- I
couldn't get this time
to care for my baby.
So I went to the benefits
department in advance.
And I was like look, this
was definitely an oversight.
There's no way
you intended this.
There's no way you meant
for this to happen.
It's not even possible.
But they wouldn't
give me an answer.
And months went by, no answer.
And then, because
it's my family,
and we can't have
a normal birth,
my wife went in for her
35 week appointment.
And she had very scary, serious
symptoms from preeclampsia,
which even in 2015, if
preeclampsia becomes eclampsia,
it's deadly.
It's scary.
So anyway, they had to induce.
So while we're in the hospital
room, I'm messaging work.
Like hey, am I going to
get the 10 weeks or not?
Because a dad like me
could only get two weeks.
We were the exception.
And they wouldn't
give me an answer.
So 11 days later, I'm home,
holding my 4-pound premie,
and taking care of my
sick wife and my two boys,
and messaging work.
Am I going back to
work now or not?
And that's when they said no.
That's when they said no,
you cannot have this policy.
No explanation,
just straight up no.
So the rest of the
story's in the book,
but I'm going to tell
you all two things
that I want you
to know right now.
Oh by the way, so this is
"The New York Times" story.
Take a look at this though.
It's funny.
So I don't really like
that picture of me,
because I look so angry.
I look very pensive and angry.
But look at this.
They drew this picture.
And this is a Mac computer,
so I forget how you scroll.
Take a look at the
picture they drew.
I think that's hilarious.
To me, that's a much better
summary of the situation
that I was going-- go home.
So that's "The New
York Times" take on it.
So there are two
things that I want you
to know about what happened.
And by the way, you can
see how cute she's gotten.
There she is recently with me.
So anyway, this was an updated
story that they did recently.
So two things I want you to
know about what happened.
One is that when we
took this legal action
against the policy, filing
a charge with the Equal
Employment Opportunity
Commission, which
is the EEOC, the responses
that came in blew us away,
blew me away.
I couldn't believe it.
The responses were
wild, and they
came in from men's groups
and women's groups, mom blogs
and dad blogs, from
conservatives and liberals,
from across the racial
spectrum, the economic spectrum,
from people across the country.
So it was like I unleashed
the floodgates of love,
all these people
saying, we support you.
So as a journalist,
I became fascinated.
Why do people care about
my family's little--
I figured there would be some
coverage, but not like that.
It was huge. "The Today
Show" was talking about us.
And so I started digging
into these policies.
What is it about
our situation that's
galvanizing so many people?
And that's when I came to
understand that we are all,
all in, that everyone who wants
to change the system so we have
real gender equality
in America, that we're
all in the same boat.
There's no gender
war on this stuff.
We're not fighting
with each other.
We're all up against
these structures,
these backward structures that
are holding all of us back.
So that's what I
explore in here.
And this is what I focus on;
laws, workplace policies,
and stigmas.
These are the three
categories of things
that need to be fixed.
We have these laws that
stick us in the past.
We have workplace
policies in many places--
fortunately not here,
as we'll talk about--
but in many places around
the country that are still
acting as gender police,
pushing women to stay home,
pushing men to stay at
work, taking options away.
And the biggest
problem we have of all
is stigmas, the
stigmas that are more
powerful than anything else.
Even if you change
the laws, even
if you change the
policies, you still
can't end up fixing anything
unless you fix the stigmas.
Now, let's get to
some good news.
There are a lot of
companies, especially
out here, in this part of the
country, that are doing really
well, that have a
policy, and you know this
very well-- that
have policies that
are allowing for men and women
to have time to do care giving.
And that's really important.
In fact, Google, you
can see right there,
in the center of that
image, was recently
named-- this is the new
website called "Fatherly."
These guys are great.
They've written about my book.
I've done some pieces for them.
They wrote "The 50 Best
Places to Work For New Dads."
He's Google, at number one.
So what we're seeing
is-- especially
out in this part of the country,
especially in the tech sector,
in Silicon Valley-- and
you can see some of these
are also more
traditional businesses.
But especially out here, in the
valley, in this whole region,
we have a world.
We have a set up
in which people are
able to take time,
whether men or women,
to care for the
children, or if there's
another kind of care giving.
But we don't have that in
the rest of the country.
This way of thinking
has not caught
on in the rest of the country.
So we have that problem.
And then we also have the
problem with our laws.
Now, I mentioned
earlier that we are
the only country that doesn't
have any paid maternity leave.
But no one ever talks about why.
When I came to understand this,
suddenly I understood why.
The reason we don't have
this is so obvious to me now.
It's that our work culture is
based on that old mentality.
So why would we possibly
need to pay women?
She's a woman.
She's supposed to stay home.
Who needs her money?
That's the thinking
behind all of it.
And the thinking for
men is why would he
possibly need paternity leave?
He's a man.
His role is to stay at work.
It's easy to think that we've
come a long way, as a nation.
But then there was an article
recently in "The Miami Herald"
in which they interviewed
a bunch of CEOs.
And they asked people just about
the concept of paternity leave.
It was just a
straight up question.
What are your thoughts
on paternity leave?
And several CEOs said
it should never exist.
And one of them said,
no only if the woman is
physically incapacitated, which
brings us to the next part.
So we got the laws
and the policies.
But by far, the biggest problem
that we have are the stigmas.
Men are punished
in the workplace,
in all these
traditional workplace.
It happens a lot
for taking time off
for any kind of care giving.
And the stories that I have from
these guys are heartbreaking,
and you'll see them in the book.
It's wild what
they've gone through.
This one man was
refused the time
that he's legally entitled
to because his boss told him,
women are supposed to
take care of the babies,
unless they're in
a coma or dead.
That's what his boss said.
Another thing I have in the
book was I got a call at work.
His wife was really scared.
They were both really scared.
The placenta had
stopped working.
She was at 37 weeks.
The baby wasn't moving.
They needed to
induce right away.
By the way, if anybody watching
this is pregnant, don't worry.
This is all very, very unusual.
It's not going to happen to you.
But extremely-- all of it,
it's a lot of horror stories
that I've had to learn.
So anyway, so he got this
call, and he ran out.
He just missed the
rest of that day
and then the rest of that week.
So he just missed
two days after that,
came back to work on Monday.
His boss called him
in and rebuked him.
How dare you take
off so much time?
Don't you know you're
needed around here?
And that boss was a pregnant
woman, which surprised me
when I first heard it and
surprises some other people,
but it does not
surprise the lawyers who
are leading this fight,
because these lawyers know
that there are gender police
who are men and women.
And the thinking for some women
who are acting as gender police
is well, wait a second.
I'm a woman, so
I'll take time off.
But you're a man.
Why would you need time off?
You're supposed to stay home!
That's the whole idea.
That's what men do.
So these are the kinds of things
that I talk about in here.
But I said earlier,
there are two things
I want you to know about how
I took on this legal action.
That was the first.
The second is that as
a result, the company
revolutionized its policy and
made it much, much better.
I knew that I was fighting
for a better business.
I knew that a better policy--
because I'd been covering this,
and I'd been covering
economies around the world.
I knew how this works.
I knew that it's
better for businesses
to have better policies.
You attract and retain
better employees,
as you very well know.
It helps you compete.
The company, if
you ask them, they
will tell you that the change
they made to the policy,
it was a win-win, that it
worked really well for them.
There was so much
coverage in my case.
People were talking about it.
The company obviously
heard the rallying cry.
And they said, we've got
to do something about this.
So now, men and
women get more time,
as a result of the change.
What they did was
before, a dad like
me could only get two weeks.
Now, a dad like me can
get six paid weeks.
Women now get paid
their six weeks
for care giving on
top of their time
for physical recovery, which
is what businesses are supposed
to do, according to
federal guideline,
separate physical recovery
time from care giving time.
So women are getting
the six weeks
of care giving leave,
plus six or eight weeks,
depending on the kind
of birth that they had.
So the company now
has a better policy
that's paid off for
just about everybody.
But while we are
seeing these changes,
we're not seeing enough of them.
And there are two big ways
that we need to fix this.
One is we need to do
something about the lies,
because as long as people
believe that dads are lazy,
that dads don't do anything,
that dads aren't helping
with their families, people
who believe that will never
support paternity leave,
will never support equality.
Unfortunately my
industry, journalism,
keeps blowing it all the time.
And this is a perfect example.
So Pew Research has messed
up a lot of stuff on this.
But in my industry, I've
spent 10 years at NPR,
10 years at CNN,
everyone goes by Pew,
no matter what they said.
So this is an example.
Pew Research wrote this.
"Another Gender Gap-- Men
Spend More Time in
Leisure Activities."
And then, as a
result of that, you
have all of these not
obnoxious headlines.
The leisure gap-- why
women are losing their time
to just chill out.
Men have more time
for fun than women do.
And this is the
worst one of all.
I found this from "Time."
The moral of the
story, whether it's
the week day or
the weekend, dads
need to spend less time on the
golf course and watching TV,
and more time helping their
wives take out the trash
and play with the kids; those
naughty, lazy, lame dads.
If you believed
this, you would never
ever support the idea
of a man staying home,
because what's he going to do?
He's going to sit around
till his wife gets home.
Here's what the
research actually says.
Pew Research looked at something
called the American Time Use
Survey.
This is government data.
In this survey,
dads interviewed,
they broke down what
a typical day is like.
Dads listed 20 more minutes as
being for leisure or sports.
What Pew did not mention is
that moms listed 20 more minutes
as being for sleep.
What we actually have
is an incredible parity.
We've achieved a kind of a
egalitarianism in the home
that no one realizes
we have, because there
are all these obnoxious
headlines out there that
make people think that
this is about gender war.
It makes people think that if
the men would just stay up,
everything would be fixed.
But the men and the women
today are all in this together,
and this is the reality.
Unfortunately, I've tried.
I tried to get
Per to correct it.
I've contacted news agencies
that wrote these headlines.
And so far, it's not
getting anywhere.
So this is how I feel every
time I see this pop up again.
I love gifs, by the way.
So I explain in the
book, and I want
to show you this
one part that it's
really important for everyone
watching to understand.
"Today's dads and
moms work equally
on behalf of their families.
When you combine paid work
with household chores and child
care, they put in just about
the same amount of time."
And this is true in
every combination.
If you have a working father and
a stay-at-home mom, a working
mom and a stay-at-home
dad, two working parents--
in every combination
you have overall,
the amount of time being put
in on behalf of your family
is the same.
People have an equal
commitment to their families.
Now, moms spend more of those
hours at home, on average.
And that has to do
with these stigmas.
They're the stigmas that men
are facing in the workplace,
and then women are facing
stigmas in both directions.
It's awful.
Some women lose
work opportunities
because they have bosses who
think they should be home,
because they're women.
So there are many
studies that show this.
If a man whose a boss has
two employees, one's a dad,
one's a mom, and there's a
really important project which
is a great opportunity, then
often he will say to the woman,
no, no, no, no, no.
You go home.
He's got this.
So women are losing out
on opportunities that way.
But then women are
also getting jobs
just the way men
are when they do
have caregiving
responsibilities, which
is why it's so good to
be here because places
that are changing the culture
are what we need more of.
So this is part of this.
But another big thing we need
in this country and, ultimately,
the best thing we
can do to fix this
is to establish laws that
make clear to everyone
that men and women
can be caregivers
and that it will
benefit everyone.
And the good news is that
we already have this.
We're in California right now.
This is one of the
places that has.
Three states have
this-- paid family
leave policies, which are run
by a public system and not
by individual businesses--
California, New Jersey,
Rhode Island.
I've looked at a lot of
policies over the years.
I've covered the stimulus.
I've covered so much
about businesses.
I've never seen as successful
a policy in general
for businesses as this.
The way it works is it
operates as an insurance policy
so people pay a tiny
little bit of their payroll
into this fund.
That fund then pays you if you
need six weeks of paid family
leave, and this is not
just caring for a child.
You can see the picture
I chose to use there.
This is caring for an
elderly parent or a spouse
or yourself after an illness.
All these things are covered.
And what places
have started to find
is that when they have
these public policies,
women will take time off
and then so will men.
And these businesses
have been forced
to see that a man can
take time off and then
come back to work and be
just as good an employee
as he was before.
So this new idea needs
to catch on nationally,
and this is what we're
pushing for right now.
I was just in New Hampshire
pushing presidential candidates
on both sides.
I was in Washington having
meetings on Capitol Hill.
And this is the effort
that's under way.
And I'm also talking to small
businesses along the way
because, unfortunately,
there is some resistance
to getting the
public policy that we
need on a national level.
Republicans in
general-- it's not
on their radar,
which is frustrating.
I keep saying Republicans.
This is a perfect
conservative issue.
This is about a family value
and proven good for business.
So why don't you
line up behind it.
But because technically
it involves a tax,
I explain in here,
there are a lot
of people are concerned
about how that
will play in their districts.
I'm working with
businesses in the meantime
and helping them understand
creative solutions-- things
that small businesses can do.
I was just in Madison,
Wisconsin speaking
with tech entrepreneurs that
have small, small offices.
But a lot of these places that
are doing creative solutions
win over their employees.
A lot of employees have
told me that the number one
thing they want wasn't
some block of paid family
leave-- it was a
conversation-- to have
bosses who will say to them,
OK, we want to keep you.
We value you.
What can we do?
How can we work together here?
When companies start to do that,
it makes all the difference
in the world.
So this is some of
what I'm up to now.
I'd like to share
this because I'm
happy to see that the
message is spreading.
That's from when I had
meetings on Capitol Hill.
I'm going off to Oxford
in a couple of weeks.
We're going to talk
about it there.
In the top right
there, you'd see
I was meeting the other day.
I met the first lady of Texas.
She's a Republican,
and she said to me,
these are nonpartisan issues.
And it was great to
have her saying that.
This is from when I
was in New Hampshire.
I like to show this
picture because you
can look at all
the businesses that
were sponsoring my talk
there, and so it is a sign.
Businesses are ready to
have this conversation more
than people thought they were.
A lot of businesses, I'm
starting consult with them now,
and they're talking to
me, and they're saying,
OK, we want to
build new policies.
What do we do?
How do we start?
And that's exciting.
And this just happened
the other day.
I was pinned by the UN
He for She Movement.
Now, some who will be watching
this recorded later on.
Hopefully, by then,
I'll understand
exactly what this means.
I know that I'm supposed to help
represent this movement now.
And I'm a big fan of He for She.
But I'm going to find
out in a few weeks
exactly how that plays out.
And the fact that He for She
exists is a sign of the times.
That we are the
generation of men
that were raised
by feminists who
want to advance gender equality
and make it really happen.
The other thing I'm able
to do is talk to people
and talking to lawyers
now and others about how
to communicate these ideas.
I know that I was in an unusual
situation with my legal case
because, yes, I had
a strong argument.
But I was able to argue it.
I knew how to say it because
I happen to be professionally
a communicator.
So I was able to turn that
into a real conversation,
and that placed pressure
on the business.
So I'm talking to
groups right now
and helping them learn how to
communicate about these ideas
and how to make
this thing happen.
A lot of people who work
here at Google are Gen Y,
and I have a great
quote here that is true.
It speaks to what's happening
with the new workforce.
This is part of
what gives me hope.
Younger workers
now are expecting,
and you're seeing
when you're hiring
I'm sure, younger workers
expect to be able to have a life
outside of work, not
just caring for children,
caring for anyone, and
just having a life.
They might take kite
surfing twice a week.
They expect the ability
to still live and not give
their entire schedules
over to the company.
The workforce has changed.
"To attract and retain
Gen X, now Gen Y, you have to
take care of these lifestyle
needs."
That's from Cynthia
Calvert, and she
is running an agency
that works with companies
to change their
policies, and she's
absolutely right about that.
By the way, that picture of
Gen Y is a little too stylized.
But it was the only public
domain photo I could find.
So if anybody rolls their
eyes when they see that,
don't worry.
I did too.
I like to leave
people with this idea.
And then if any of you
here have questions,
let me know, and if any of
you are watching afterwards,
go ahead and send them to me.
I'd love to hear from
absolutely everyone.
I encourage people to think
about what your first dream was
in your life, and not
an overnight dream,
but your first
aspirational dream
because when people
think about this,
the first thing that comes to
mind usually a lot of people
tell me they want to be an
astronaut, and firefighters,
and ballet dancers.
What astronaut?
Astronaut for you?
Right.
There you go.
And that was my
first thought too.
I was like maybe I
wanted to be a cowboy.
But we're wrong.
That's not what the
first dream was.
We all had the same first dream.
The first dream was
to be held and loved.
And you see that in
the eyes of any baby.
But we had that dream before
we could form memories.
So it's primal.
It's literally primal.
It's like the
first experience we
had when we arrived
in this world
that automatic knowledge
that that's what we want.
And there's a lot of
ways to experience that.
It's not just about
having children.
It's about having
time with friends
that you care about or
your romantic partners
or whatever it is, but
ultimately making sure
that you can have
that in your life
however it plays out for you is,
to me, the story of humanity.
So I mentioned
earlier that my son
is alive because of innovation
that innovation is everything.
We're at a place that's
all about innovation.
This place exists
because of innovation.
To me, the positive
story of humanity
just boils down to
these two things.
One, we innovate, we
adapt, and survive.
And two, we love.
That's what we do.
That's what we are.
So making sure that you
have a life in which you
can do both in which you
have work-life balance,
work-life integration,
is actually
the most natural thing.
The whole idea of work-life
conflict is actually unnatural,
and it is forwarded by this
entire sexist structure
because the system was
designed one person here,
one person there.
It wasn't designed to
have one person to want
to have a life in both places.
So what we need to do
is listen to nature.
We want to do great work,
and we want to innovate,
and we want to have
that first primal dream.
We want to be able to love.
And to me, that's what
it is to be all in.
All right, so thank you to
those of you who are here.
Thank you to those of you
who are watching there.
I want to end with
a happy little note.
I showed you those depressing
ads at the beginning, right?
Take a look at what happened.
So the most watched as of the
entire year are Super Bowl day.
This past January
during the Super Bowl,
there were all
these pro-dad ads,
which shows that the
message is catching on.
This is one of the best.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Daddy.
[SPLASH]
-Dada.
-Daddy.
[CRYING]
-Dad?
-Daddy.
-Dad.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Dad!
[GIGGLES]
-Dove Men Plus Care--
care makes a man stronger.
Share how care makes you
stronger with #RealStrength.
[END PLAYBACK]
JOSH LEVS: That's
a sign that's what
happens when you fight for
an all in world all right
thanks to those of you here.
Tell me if you have any
questions because I'm also
happy to answer any questions
that you guys may have.
And if not, that's also OK.
We can tie up.
Oh, and let me show you guys
something, everyone watching,
I have a way for
you to contact me.
I use everything,
including Google+.
I encourage you all.
There you go.
That's the way to contact me.
I love to hear from everybody.
And also I link
in with everyone.
They say not to link
They say, only link in
with people you know.
I don't know why they say that.
I link in with
absolutely everyone.
Did we link in?
We linked in, right?
Didn't we?
Well, we need to.
AUDIENCE: Maybe a
two-part question.
One is, is this your
full-time thing now?
And at what point
in the journey did
you recognize this
could be-- assuming
that's the answer--
the full-time thing.
JOSH LEVS: Yeah, I'm now
doing this full time.
Yeah it's wild what happened.
My book came out
in May, and we were
hoping that it would
get some people talking.
And fortunately, the
response has been incredible
just in terms of
getting invited places
to talk about this issue.
People want to hear
about the issue.
So, yes, I recently
officially left CNN
because I was on leave, and
it was during the book--
and now I'm booked all
the way through the end
of the year with events.
So I'm happy to, yeah, say
I'm doing this full time.
And it's working
out well so far.
Now, fortunately, I get
to come places like here
and meet people this week in
San Francisco was amazing.
I spoke at Twitter and
Nerd Wallet and Stanford,
and I'm doing a big
conference keynote tomorrow.
And on Friday, I'm going to GE.
So there's a lot
of places I want
to have these conversations.
I just got back from
Austin where I was
working with Liberty Mutual.
They're doing all
this great stuff.
So, yes, it is.
And when did I realize it.
I knew it could
be an opportunity,
but I didn't know until
this book came out,
and I started getting
all these invitations
that it could be full time.
So I would say probably
like August, September,
I started to realize that
this can go somewhere along.
And the great thing
is now I travel.
So I could be this
massive hypocrite.
Family time is important.
I say, well, I
travel all the time.
So I try to pack all my travel
into four days at a time,
and then when I'm
home, I'm home.
Because I'm not rushing off
to a job in the morning.
So I'm taking the kids
to school, and I'm there,
and we're playing, and
we're doing everything.
So, so far, I'm managing to
find the balance that way.
But we'll see.
I just also disbelieve in taking
steps forward and believing
that there will be
solid ground under me
and not worry about what
if it all falls apart.
AUDIENCE: Wonderful.
JOSH LEVS: Thanks.
Yeah?
Yeah, sure.
AUDIENCE: So you gave props to
the Silicon Valley companies
for leading the
way in this area.
JOSH LEVS: A bunch of them.
AUDIENCE: But they're also
notorious for people going
and not taking their vacations.
They're just falling
off the edge.
So what's the interplay
with those two things?
JOSH LEVS: That is all top down.
I'm glad you asked about that.
One problem out here is that
people mythologize overworking.
And it's important not to
mythologize overworking.
Not to be like, oh, that's
such a great employee.
He works 20 hours a day.
That doesn't make
him a great employee.
He might be a great
employee and overwork,
but those two things
are coincidences.
And so it has to be
top down, and that's
the same thing with leave.
Like a lot of people
now have been asking me
about Marissa Mayer
at Yahoo who has
said that after she has twins,
she is going to take off, what?
A couple weeks, I think.
I'm keeping an eye
on Mark Zuckerberg.
They have 17 paid weeks there.
I hope he takes them.
And a lot of people
think he probably won't.
And the problem is
that it's all top down.
So when policy is on
paper, it doesn't matter.
What matters is what
happens in practice.
So what we need is to have
leaders who take vacations
as allowed and actual
vacations, so they're not
working on their vacations.
And I explain it here
that's also proven out
to be good for business
because it helps
other people have opportunity.
You're nodding your head
you know about this.
It's proven now that it helps
other people work their way up.
There's some grandparents
in the book grandads,
who did it the old, traditional
way when they had their kids.
And now, they want
to do it this way.
So they are taking care of
their grandkids one or two
days a week.
And they've shrunk their
work schedules because of it.
And the couple from in
here explained to me
that they have now learned
what they learned decades
ago which is that when
they take those days off,
they're really not working,
and when they come back,
everything's fine because their
underlings were given the trust
to really get things done.
It wasn't you have to call me
if anything at all comes up,
and the people who work there
understand that for that day,
someone else really
is in charge.
It gives other people a chance
to work their way up and learn
the business.
So long-winded
answer your question,
but it's all about top down.
We have to make this
happen top down.
That's the only way to do it.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Actually, OK.
JOSH LEVS: OK, I saw
you nodding your head
so maybe that-- were you
wondering about all the travel
and stuff?
You're like, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was going
to ask you about that,
but you answered it.
JOSH LEVS: You were going
to ask me about why do I
talk about-- yeah, it's crazy.
Like, here I am 3,000 miles
away from my kids, right?
And we Skype when we can.
Although I was also
explaining earlier that
my kids' favorite thing is
not Skype or Facebook video.
It's Google Hangout
video because I
get to put those faces on.
Have you guys done this.
You can press buttons and make
these faces appear on you.
I'm such a Google fanboy.
It's good to be here.
Yeah, and baby was
saying to me yesterday
when we were on Facebook videos.
She was like funny
face, funny face.
And I said, I can't do it.
I'm sorry.
We're not I Google
Hangout right now.
So I need your Google Hangout to
create those tools for my phone
so I could do it on my phone too
and not just on my Chromebook.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I have
another question.
So you speak at all of
these different places.
I'm curious what's the most
resistance you've faced
and how you've turned it around.
JOSH LEVS: So the good news
is that partly because I'm
a communicator, I know how to
knock down a lot of those walls
when I get somewhere.
You know, when I spoke with the
National Chamber of Commerce
in New Hampshire-- a mostly
conservative organization--
traditional views on how
a lot of things work,
but not so much gender.
They want women to
work their way up.
But the places like that get
afraid that I'm to come in
and say, oh, businesses
have to pay for everything.
It's all up to businesses.
So I start off my talk to
explain that my grandfather was
a small business
owner that he had
a tiny shop at the
edge of his driveway
that I've always understood
the importance of not
over-regulating
businesses, and that I
want businesses to thrive.
And then they start
listening to me.
The most pushback
I have ever had
is one place that I won't
name that was supposed
to give a talk at, and
they told me that they had,
I think, I like about
100 people signed up,
and then HR got
involved, and they
wanted me to jump through all
these hoops to even show up.
Like, what are going to say?
What are you going to not say?
And I explained I'm
not a Trojan horse.
I don't go to companies to try
to blow up their own policies
from the inside.
But it wasn't even
about them anymore.
It was like this and this
and this and this and this,
and by the way, you can't
talk about your book.
So I said, no, look,
it's not worth it
for me to make the
trek out there.
So there are places
that still have
that that are so afraid of
someone coming in and saying
anything that might in any
way make them look imperfect.
But people respect
their businesses
for being self-effacing and for
having conversations and being
open to new ideas.
But this is a business that
is traditional and still has
backward policies.
So there's that.
I also wrote a piece
slamming Amazon
for having no paternity leave,
which is disgusting, one
of the many problems at
Amazon, unacceptable, no.
Anyone know people
at Amazon, call them.
Tell them to do
something about it.
AUDIENCE: So it's kind of
like a prediction thing.
If you have a crystal ball, and
you're to look forward again
at the US in 10
years, do you think
there would be a federal
mandated paternity leave?
And how long would that be?
JOSH LEVS: Yeah, with the paid
family leave that we need,
I'm hoping within 10 years.
So we've got unpaid leave 1993,
which was called the Family
Medical Leave Act.
But it doesn't apply
to 40% of workers,
and even 1 in 5 companies
admit they don't even fully
comply with the law.
So this idea of what we need
now being paid family leave.
I think you've actually
got the figure right.
My hope is that within
10 years, we get it.
The problem is
messaging to people
who are afraid of anything
that has the word tax in it
because even though it's
so good for everyone,
it's proven in three
states, some people
just won't support it
because of the word tax.
The problem is that we cannot
do a state-by-state solution
because most states don't have
a structure to collect the money
and distribute it.
Like Washington State passed
paid family leave several years
ago, but they still
don't have it,
because they don't
have-- I don't even
know why they passed it.
They created it, but
don't have a structure.
They don't have a
bureaucracy in the way
that the state works that
would take in the money
and distribute it.
So we need a national policy.
So my hope is that
within the next 10 years,
the Democrats are
talking about it.
Almost all the Democrats
running for president right
now are lining up for it.
But in order to get
something through Congress,
it would need some
bipartisan support.
So it's just a handful
of brave Republicans
who will step
forward and say, yes.
Jim Daly is in here.
He's the head of Focus on
the Family, a staunchly
conservative organization.
He says in here, I opposed
FMLA, Family Medical Leave Act.
I'm embarrassed.
We should never have
been against it.
Conservatives should
have supported it.
I'm open to new things.
A bunch of Republicans
are in here.
3/4 of Republican voters
want a paid family
leave insurance policy.
So it's not really about
the general broad base.
It's about lawmakers
who are worried
about their extreme voters in
gerrymandered districts, who
will just hear the word
tax and go the other way.
So my hope is that in
10 years, we'll get it.
And I'm enough of an optimist to
believe that, yes, in 10 years,
we will have a federal
plan that makes--
and I want to understand
the stakes here.
I mean, for everything
that happened
with me-- for everything
I'm talking about-- the fact
that right now we are
tearing away parents
from their newborn children
because they can't put food
on the table without
going back to work, that
is disgusting and shameful.
And every day that
we wait, we're
making more families suffer.
So 10 years is actually in that
respect a very, very long time.
And it's depressing.
But I am hopeful
that in 10 years,
we'll get there if we have to.